yes well you know you scratch a check
and you find it Celt
because the reason these people look
vaguely Irish is because the Celts what
were here six thousand years ago long
before they reached the Iberian
Peninsula of Spain and migrated into
England this was Celtic country all
these round hills
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what I'm asking people about is
basically what sort of ideas or or
what's been most interesting or
astonishing about being in Prague
so there's your assignment the energy of
the city and the opening that's
happening and just that you can feel it
people are starting to come you know
that out in the street I woke up this
morning to hearing children's voices
playing in a playground downstairs and
it was so much fun it was like this
energy and little kids and I looked down
and they were making these wonderful
designs with rocks on the sidewalk and
was just it was it's the same kind of
thing that I hear when I'm into in kids
in the United States but it could have
this joyfulness and an energy and
meeting my friends here again I am part
of a an international community of
people doing work with sacred substances
and I never get to meet them very often
and so when we meet each other there's a
lot of stimulation and heartfelt warm
connections that we don't make the theme
of this conference was actually pretty
heavy-duty do you think it comes off as
optimistic pessimistic naive
how would you describe I think that the
theme was perfect because it's ambiguous
enough to bring all of those together
and I think all of those energies are
happening now and that's why it's it is
optimistic and pessimistic and hopeless
and hopeful and it has all of that the
energy of all the ambiguity and the
tensions involved with all of those
varies polarities sort of swirling
around and creating like an energy it
feels almost like a little bit like an
energy vortex that's happening where the
Energy's from opposite poles come around
mix together and I like some Richard
harnesses talk on the male-female coming
together in it hi
it made me feel a little bit like the
way when the sperm comes up to the egg
and there's this kind of vibration that
happens and it sort of feels a little
bit like that kind of energy full of
potential so where are you going when
you leave I've been reinterpreted
putting together plans for a protocol to
use LSD with substance abusers where
we've been given permission by the
government but we still have to go
through a review panel that has yet to
so so you'll be doing a human studies
work with LSD and other substance abuse
people need to have the diagnosis of
substance abuse what that means in that
person's life we'll find out when we
work with them but at least to the rest
of the world that's what their diagnosis
is and it allows us to have them enter
the study where will this go on
probably in Baltimore Maryland well
that's wonderful do you think it means
there's a general loosening of attitude
or there's more chaos it's a little bit
of it's more that people don't know how
to regard it and it may be that there's
still there's some opening in terms of a
few more reasonable people who have a
little bit more openness to it they're
still pretty paranoid they want to be
able to trust who's doing the work and
how can they trust people if they're
doing psychedelic work so there's still
the same catch-22
well thanks for talking okay hope you
have fun in Prague yes yeah yeah I am
are you gonna get out to the countryside
well we're probably going to go out on
Thursday in distance there's a spa
Carlsbad Bohemia and Castle Karl Steen
an hour south of here is a famous
Rosicrucian castle kinds of European
history like that's a needle it's neat
it's different you should really see
Bohemia while you're here
I wish we had made plans to go back a
lot later we're leaving on Saturdays too
bad you should put a week and have just
to wander around the countryside well
thanks for stopping by my audience is
over there and I'm talking to Terrence
well you're talking to you into camera
position so what are we going to talk
about well I'm going to ask you what has
been interesting or unexpected about
Krog or how you feel about this whole
thing is it more frivolous Eurotrash
self-congratulatory prose ooh astray or
no party what about friends of the true
revolution gathering together in the
pool yes I was saying what do you make
of the conference do you see it as
born-again Eurotrash Pozos tree or
hard-won veterans of the true revolution
gathering in the foxholes of Eastern
Europe to plot our next assault on the
barricades as it is a combination of my
long good a mixture of all of these
things um I've actually been having the
hardest time I've been having is trying
to figure out if I'm in Disneyland or
Paris or Moscow do you mean because
Prague is sort of like kind of
interference pattern formed of all three
yes it's no mesh bohemian queen and
silver lathe it's dark central Europeans
don't have this ceiling instead of like
a front and then if you go it's so
incredibly beautiful and then if you go
about three miles outside of the
boundary it's gonna like be overalls you
don't see any overalls and tell you see
if you do with the workmen on the scale
have you been into the country on the
train no well I'll tell you to my mind
what the metaphor for Czechoslovakia is
is it's all it's the green country with
the Emerald capital city with the Great
Palace and the little wizard inside and
all the happy munchkins of Bohemia
farming and making cheese and carrying
on with their butter and eggs and so on
are they well they're splitting the
country apart but more power to them I
said do you think so sure the people who
most want to leave are the poorer more
uneducated unand us realized half of the
country right-o if they want to get rid
of all this highly developed pseudo
Western European land on the western end
of things I heard this wonderful story
do you know this story that um I don't
know when this was but many years ago
the language had completely disappeared
um and one man took it upon himself to
resuscitate the language so he went kind
of crawling out into the backwoods and
found these tiny little villages were
just a few of the old people remembered
two Czechoslovakian language and he
wrote it down and cataloged it and
taught it to people and they taught it
to people and people so I teach you to
the children again and the entire
language was resuscitated from this one
man's kind of pilgrimage
to the to the sort of residuals of where
the language had been storm that a great
story it's a story because it feels it
has the potential to be metaphorical for
our time you know when when we're just
right on the brink of that long you know
well in bringing back the lost language
means presumably you bring back the
possibility of thoughts that could not
be sent that's right so it's like
reality itself you were saying and
you're bringing it back yes or things
like the genes will of plants or you
know fill metaphorical communit was a
successful story and here we are and
everyone's speaking Czech yes well you
know you scratch a check and you find it
help because the reason these people
look vaguely Irish is because the Celts
what were here six thousand years ago
long before they reached the Iberian
Peninsula of Spain and migrated in doing
this was Celtic country all these round
Hills we're talking maybe going to
Berlin maybe to Carlsbad
I think the conference is interesting
were you asking about that yeah what's
the most interesting thing you've run
across well there's the most interesting
thing but I think I wonder about the
question about that no one seems to be
asking about whether or not you know
when transpersonal psychology first hit
we all had the very optimistic feeling
that this is going to make a big dent in
the movement of history just like we all
did during the 60s revolution but this
was somehow going to blossom into some
major transformation of essentially how
people treated each other and and it
feels like now these conferences that
are going on for what 10 years 15 years
years and maybe it's time to ask that
question again
I mean what's makes us so special if if
transpersonal psychology is so wonderful
what is it done for right and it's it
working and does it have the potential
to work and what does it mean for it to
work it's and in a way I feel like
people are going up and sort of within
their own ideological frameworks
presenting the things that we've heard
them present
again and again and it might be time to
you know I miss a kind of critical
evaluation or everyone's very polite you
know and saying well is brother David
said and well is you mean no one would
dare stand up and say like god you're
not going to sing a song at the end
right or not more of your damn heart
[Laughter]
that's your what there's seventeen
hundred people's Danny van you'd the
readings have you been to lectures
because I've been making yes well yes
okay so what brings to my mind is okay
it's the medium is the message that if
you're going to create a paradigm shift
right it's about remembering that all of
the things that people been saying that
where they're this component and that
component was spirit and were nature and
were earth and we're body and we're head
and remind and we're hardened and then
you have to approach the whole thing
holistically you can't do it like this
so you think gentleman in tweed suits
with small patterns standing before
lecterns with their flies
I'm not leaving ass into the new well
I'm questioning it I can't say for sure
but I'm saying these are the questions
that feel like they're moot in the
conference and they're underground and
we used to be the underground and we
used to be the people asking those
questions and speaking them and are we
still doing are we far have we become
yep abide enough to not be willing to
ask I mean maybe it's because I'm
obsessed with one subject but it seems
to me but here's the insight which that
gives me which is our as a movement this
transpersonal thing is officiated by a
huge number people wanting to cash in on
the imagined phenomenon of addiction yes
so we're we've got 12 step up the kazoo
and I think you know the transpersonal
psychology should not be in the business
of selling people on the idea of
addiction because it is the end of moral
responsibility if you're an addict then
it's just like getting the flu or PMS or
something it's just not your fault and
you just really better get some
psychotherapy and take care of that so I
think I'm surprised that in all these
psychedelic panels and so forth there
hasn't been a real attempt to say look
we need pharmacological intervention
we're hardwired for bashing out the
brains of wooly mammoths that's what
would put it I don't know that I
entirely agree with you but that's what
would give it
Edd's that i don't feel like the
conference has too nice
they're too nice and they're too timid
and you can't be an underground and be
timid that's right right so what happens
when transpersonal listen becomes
somewhat mainstream not that it is
entirely it becomes problematic it's
just what happened to the 60s it gets
kind of bought off and then people are
selling their books and their careers
are established and they're afraid to
make those kinds of challenges nothing
could be great to have a psychedelic
panel or you know mixed with the 12-step
were you in the psychedelic panel no
because it was incredibly polite I even
found myself being polite and thinking
things that I thought were [ __ ] and
just letting it fly by because I thought
all so what is it with suppose somebody
says they were saying how can we make
psychedelics more respectable and
somebody suggested that they publish a
journal in which you didn't sign your
articles and you didn't give the names
of the patients so if I thought to
myself you know political godlessness
reaches mega proportions that's not how
we do it you do it by standing up and
being counted not refusing to put your
name on your research everything that
you've already not called underneath
that see I think that I still have that
sort of Socratic model in my mind I
think that that wisdom comes through
some kind of dialectical dialogue and
that if you if you really go for the
disparate points of view then you can
form your own synthesis that
somehow embodies the truth in some way
it may not be exactly the same but I
should have heard the truth of people's
orientation so it's like the eaching
says knowledge that is not I don't know
how it puts it exactly but basically
knowledge that is not created out of
interaction with critics is sterile
right because there's a feedback loop
right which there is an every living
system there's some kind of nothing to
polish right right right and one of the
things I've experienced to know that I
want to go in camera saying this is that
the workshop that I fell or the lecture
whatever that was the most interesting
with somebody I'd never heard of it
wasn't one of the stars of the personal
world whose his stuff I enjoyed it was
this woman she talked about this
intergenerational if I call
psychological patterning that go on and
for me it was very contemporaneous with
experiences that I'm having so to hear
somebody articulate them even though it
was a new information it was confirming
experiences that I was currently having
and so I thought that very moving to me
she didn't read it papers she just
talked and she's not a big star and she
didn't tell stories that I'd ever heard
before and I thought well maybe that's
something going on here that I'm not so
aware of that there's sort of some of
the lesser-known people who have had to
hone their skills more because they
can't rely on
and they're not in the clip right there
are the ones who are really cultivating
some of this more about God Sensibility
no I think you're absolutely right once
you're a known quantity in the media
you're almost self defined out of
relevance this is called the dancing
bear phenomenon I hate it I'm sure
you're aware of it as a performer no
it's why as Reinhard had to paint black
canvases till the day they planted in
and because you know you become defined
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
class whoa can we can we stop we've been
on camera two hours and 20 min